so you're charles d dirk in the 1950s
you're a former alcoholic who's seen the
lights and now wants to help others find
their way so you decide to put your own
twist on the alcoholics anonymous
program but with your program you help
addicts recover with a more aggressive
approach you call your program synonym
and you center the entire thing around a
group treatment technique known as the
game
during the game everyone puts their
focus on one member of the group and for
hours everyone takes turns bullying and
humiliating the person of focus they
tell them everything that's wrong with
them and pick apart every detail of
their personality until the person of
focus is basically a hollowed-out shell
the game is meant to break a person
until they're humbled enough to be built
back up better oftentimes the game would
escalate to the point of violence and
everyone in synonym was required to
participate in the game
yeah sure these practices weren't really
useful in actually helping people but in
a sadistic way it was a very effective
way to control them to make them
submissive to you
even though you started synonym as a
pseudo-recovery program for alcoholics
it quickly blossed them into something
very different a brutal and fast
spreading cults
synonyms spread throughout california
and the group became more and more
disturbing as they grew members were
required to shave their heads bald they
made couples who entered together break
apart and recouple with new people
synonym members were even sterilized and
forced to have abortions
things were getting really out of hand
and by 1991 synonym was officially shut
down
it seemed like this was the end of the
story but it was only the beginning
synonym ended up inspiring a slew of
people to take the coast's techniques
and make it into a business and the
result was a new very dark industry the
business of reforming troubled teenagers
[Music]
former members of synonym created groups
like the phoenix house the seed and
straight incorporated a collection of
businesses that thrived on one thing
exploiting the desperate parent of
teenagers
these programs made big promises of
fixing your kids pot smoking habits
terrible attitudes depression anxiety
homosexuality to pray the gay away your
son just needs to learn that he can be
straight if he chooses to be
if you were a parent stressed about your
kid's future this sounded amazing i can
outsource my parenting to these camps
all they had to do was sign their name
on the dotted line and let these
businesses take away their troubled teen
and boom after some time they would come
on a respectful well-mannered young
adult
but what's their magic trick how are
they fixing these teenagers well through
straight up torture to put it bluntly
breaking down their spirit until they
beg for it to stop and unfortunately
many of these troubled teens don't
survive the programs like 15 year old
erica harvey erica became ill at the
catherine freer wilderness program she
was forced to keep hiking for hours
until she died that afternoon of a heat
stroke in dehydration in 2002 or 12 year
old alex harris alex was attending hope
youth ranch in 2005. he died after
begging for medical help from staff
members only to be forced to keep
running laps or seven-year-old angelica
arndt who went into cardiac arrest at
rice lake clinic after being asphyxiated
while being restrained in 2006
and this isn't a thing of the past it's
still happening to this day right now in
2016 15 year old janaya barnharts died
at above surf after being restrained in
a full body wrap in 2019
seventeen-year-old curse of simmons
committed suicide in a bathroom at west
ridge academy in 2020 16 year old
cornelius friedrich was killed after a
violent 11-minute restraint at lakeside
academy his crime throwing a sandwich
kidnapping and torturing teens is
usually thought to be illegal but today
is turned into the billion dollar
troubled teen industry
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking to create your own
successful business like a treble team
boot camp for example then you're going
to need every single advantage you can
get because it's a competitive world out
there and one super easy advantage you
can have is having better sleep with
hustle culture these days most of your
competitors don't get enough sleep
because they think it's cool and noble
but if you get enough sleep you'll have
better cognitive performance than them
better memory than them and a giant list
of other benefits as well that is why i
have always taken my sleep very
seriously i've always been the type of
person who takes my sleep seriously
because i know just how important it is
for your productivity memory and more
isn't it weird that we have these things
like prescription glasses to help you
see better but not a prescription
mattress that's tailor made to help you
sleep better well that is where helix
comes in with helix all you have to do
is fill out a quick and easy sleep quiz
you'll tell them if you'll be sleeping
alone or with someone else what position
you tend to sleep in how firm you like a
mattress to be and if you have any back
pain and boom that is it helix matches
you with the perfect mattress for you
that will give you the best sleep
possible you can then grab some
accessories like a bed frame or weighted
blankets and then your matches will be
delivered right to your door in a small
box so that it's easy to set up on your
own you'll also get a hundred night
sleep trial so if you don't like it for
whatever reason you'll get a full refund
based on my results heels match me with
their sunset lux mattress and guys it is
incredible the firmness is exactly what
i was looking for it supports the way i
sleep perfectly and i actually miss my
helix when i have to stay in hotels
where the mattress isn't made for me
they ship for free within the us their
mattresses come with a 10 year warranty
plus they have financing options and
flexible payment plans so if you want to
improve your sleep go to helixsleep.com
jaketran or click the link below for up
to 200 off your helix sleep mattress and
two free pillows that's helix sleep.com
that's jake trevor up to 200 off in two
free pillows thanks to helix for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
over 50 000 kids are sent to some form
of trouble team program every year in
the us and there are a few different
types remedial boarding schools boot
camps religious academies gay conversion
camps wilderness programs and youth
rehab centers these things can be run by
private companies non-profits or
religious groups and kids get sent to
these camps for a variety of reasons
sure there are children who get sent
away from big issues like addiction or
committing crimes i could send you to
jail and i would not lose one bit of
sleep over it
but then there are also kids who get
centered for depression anxiety eating
disorders their gender identity or
sexual orientation there are teens in
foster care and group homes who are
turned over to these camps simply
because it's convenient for the states
for each and every kid troubled teen
camps make millions of dollars
some for-profit programs earn as much as
800 per day for every child so if a
school has 250 prisoners i mean students
they could be making around 200 000
every single day and here's how you can
do it yourself
[Music]
the first step to getting a program like
this off the ground is by targeting the
people with all the power the parents i
mean the whole reason we can take away
kids in the first place is because
they're under 18 they're too young to
have all their rights specifically we go
for parents who are desperate and don't
know how to help their kids the ones who
are willing to pay anything to fix their
little angel then we tell them our
program is the exact solution they've
been looking for
all he wanted to do at the time was to
help him and now we are all facing
together the challenge of finding out
this was the worst thing that ever
happened to him so this is the binder i
kept all my letters from my mom in my
dearest teddy you hate me you never
thought you could hate me more than you
did yesterday you're about to enter a
school that will help you i am crying as
i write this i am scared that you will
never forgive me or understand that i am
saving your life xo i love you mom
but the problem you're gonna run into is
that nobody is gonna agree to get
shipped off to a random program that
promises to fix them especially not
teenagers but no worries because we have
a handy solution for laps just kidnap
them seriously literally just kidnapped
them but don't worry because it's all
totally legal remember that anything
about teens not having rights that is
the useful parts
in the u.s minors don't have medical
autonomy which means that your parent or
legal guardian can give consent for you
and since my mom had full custody they
literally only needed her signature to
snatch me up in the middle of the night
and fly me across the country the best
way to do it is to take them in the
middle of the nights you know a sneak
attack so they're not prepared and there
are plenty of services available to do
your legal kidnapping for you like
united secure youth transport agency or
next step youth transports their company
names sound vague enough but trust me
they'll do anything it takes to get the
job done here's how it will go down two
big intimidating guys will show up in
the middle of the nights the parents
will direct them to the sleeping child's
bedroom and then the teen is woken up by
the agents and tell them that they can
do this the easy way or the hard way and
trust me you would want to do it the
easy way once they get them out of the
house that's it the teen is taken to a
different state or sometimes even to a
different country where the program is
located the entire time there aren't
being told what's happening
there was this knock at the door and i
remember kind of looked at my mom cause
i was wondering you know who that might
be and it was these two
really big people and the first guy he
grabbed my wrist and slammed my arms
against the counter and next thing i
knew there was like a knee up against
the back of my knee and my knees were on
the ground and it all happened so fast
all the guys said is you can do this the
easy way or the hard way either way
you're coming with us and did you know
where you were going what was happening
to you not at all i remember waking up
the next morning and just being so
bewildered you know here i am just i
don't know a soul i have no direction i
just went through this insane experience
of being kidnapped the night before
they're like can you do this the easy
way
we're gonna do this the hard way these
guys have been hired by my parents and
got legally kidnapped so when i was 16 i
was kidnapped in the middle of the night
and taken from connecticut to utah and
things only get worse with them when
they arrive at the sites i mean we've
got to make sure the parents get their
money's worth rights
[Music]
by the time the teenagers get to the
program they are terrified and confused
unsure about where they are or what's
happening
no one told me what was happening or
where i was going until i was dumped in
the middle of the desert and it turns
out i was brought to wilderness rehab
getting bugged into a team program is
shockingly similar to getting booked
into prison the teens are strip searched
and have a supervised shower often by
staff members of the opposite sex we're
talking about 13 year old girls being
strip searched and watched in the shower
by adult men
i just turned 13 years old they did a
full intake cavity search i had to strip
naked they
you know did this whole thing where they
had you spread your legs and shake and
then had a staff member
march me to the showers it was a male
staff member and
so i had a supervised shower which was
also very traumatizing
i remember the water being very cold
they took me to what was going to be my
bedroom and i went to bed
and some parts of the intake at these
camps are even worse than prisons this
girl said that when she first arrived to
a program called turn about ranch she
was forced to sit up without sleeping
for three days straight she wasn't
allowed to shower she just had to sit
there for days everybody there you see
you're in the middle of nowhere you know
there's nowhere to run if you try to run
out there you're either they're gonna
find you you're gonna get in more
trouble or if you do get away you're
gonna get eaten by a coyote or something
another anonymous teen said that when he
refused to take out his piercings during
intake the staff members ripped them off
through his flesh he still has scars
today
[Music]
the teenager's experience only worsens
as time goes on
your mission for this class
is to accomplish a change in your life
but in order to make that happen you
must sweat
you must work for it
you must go through the challenge in the
fire once they're stuck in the program
all their communication is monitored
their letters home are read and their
calls are listened to by staff teens are
punished big time if they dare to try to
tell their parents about what is really
happening to them and a lot is happening
it's frustrating because i know she
didn't know the truth and that she was
kind of falling for this act that i was
putting on that i knew i had to put on
trouble team programs today mainly use
the same principle synonyms started with
tearing people down to make them into
something different really they strip
you from your whole personality you have
to act like just whoever they want you
to act like i was so afraid of doing
something wrong all the
time they do this by cultivating an
environment of constant fear and stress
with a few different techniques like
shame by having sessions similar to the
game where the group verbally abuses a
single individual until they break
monarch
had a form of like public humiliation
call to see it on a seat you were not
allowed to be spoken to
and you could not speak and then you
would go out in a war or isolation and
solitary confinement as a punishment
you're in a cement room with nothing
technically you were supposed to sit the
entire time and be quiet but of course
after a while you start mentally
breaking so i would do things like sing
i would be restrained for that um you
know or try to like move around in my
cell and get restrained for that schmidt
where you're isolated where you're
secluded from the rest of the population
oftentimes and then you have to do this
activity where you pick up wood
in upstate new york from one parking lot
to the other or it's a circle you're not
taking away basic knees like a bed
clothing warmth
they take away like necessity privileges
like sleeping on a bed eating good food
not being cold force feeding medication
without telling them what it is
they would prescribe everyone all these
pills
i didn't know what they were giving me
i just feel so tired constant manual
labor or physical activity without
breaks camps basically doing manual
labor all day long
it was just constant yelling at like
boot camp style and then you would go
out and work
for
eight to ten hours then there are the
tactics that cross the boundaries even
further some teams were forced to eat so
much food that they had to keep a bucket
next to them to constantly throw up
during meals other teens have their food
limited to the point of feeling hungry
and lightheaded all the time in a lot of
states these programs are legally
allowed to withhold food and water as a
form of punishments
i'm like please kind of just go home
i've already been through so much i
promise i'll never go to a club again
please like i i can't go back to these
places like you've no idea
along with other stuff involving teenage
girls i probably can't talk about on
youtube
[Applause]
all of this happens because the industry
is completely removed from any watchful
eyes we found out after we graduated
from these this place and left
that it was even regulated the state of
new york had no idea what they were
providing these kids they're not
regulated by the government and these
are kidnapped kids in the middle of
remote locations these programs are free
to do whatever they want because no one
is watching
most of the staff of these programs have
zero experience with children or mental
health and did you have any experience
with children with education like
absolutely none did you feel like you
had to go along with it
i thought they must be licensed
one former staff member told the press
that he wouldn't treat a dog end quote
the way he was ordered to treat children
at his facility worst of all there's
barely any proof of all this abuse
happening there are no cameras or phones
to record what's happening it's just a
staff member's word against a troubled
teen you have no evidence you don't have
a phone there they don't have cameras
they're like there's no evidence of none
of this and obviously all the staff is
in on it but teens from these programs
are finally starting to get their
stories out and there are thousands of
them
when i was removed from my community
without warning without having the
ability to talk or tell anybody where i
was going when you get there they tell
you to get naked they strip search you
and then they give you a new pair of
clothes that you have for the whole time
and a backpack that usually weighs about
50 to 75 of your weight
[Music]
[Music]
kids who attend troubled teen programs
are actually more likely to recommit a
crime when they get out so these
programs make things way worse than they
were before and it tears families apart
i mean would you talk to your parents
anymore if they paid to have you
kidnapped and held hostage and the kids
who managed to get out of these programs
with a lifetime of ptsd and baggage are
actually the lucky ones because some of
them don't even make it out alive nearly
200 kids have died at these programs
since the 70s and guess what it's still
happening right now right now as you're
watching this video there are thousands
of children in the woods or at boarding
schools or at religious programs being
held against their will they're being
abused and they're dying just three
months ago from the time of recording
this video a young girl at maple lake
academy died she had complained about
medical issues for days but nobody
brought her to a doctor they just
ignored her on january 16 2022 she was
found dead
as of 2022 this industry profits 1.2
billion dollars a year
and there is no end in sights
pretty insane story that i had no idea
what's happening before i started
researching this video let me know what
you thought in the comments below and if
you're new here my name is jake and we
run one of the biggest channels on
youtube for documentaries on money power
and crime so click that subscribe button
below we make multiple videos just like
this one for free every single week and
if you want longer ones or even more
controversial to the point where i can't
post them publicly click that join
button below we have a really good one
coming out that i can't wait for you
guys to see and if you join and you
don't think it's worth it you can email
me and i will personally refund you the
money you can follow me on instagram
jaytran.il watch out for fake accounts i
will never message you asking for money
or whatever but that's gonna wrap it up
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you